the only common thread of the
Investments the boards I sit on the only
Common Thread there's a million
variables of what makes somebody win
sometimes the COO she or he is just too
talented and they will it to
success other times there's some random
outside factors people get caught at
time there's things but the only Common
Thread that I see in the world of making
something win is attention is the number
one asset I'm just extremely excited to
be here because I've been very fortunate
in my career to be able to speak on a
lot of stages but as you can imagine
some stages are just a little more
authentic to you than others given how
my career has played out the founders
the alcohol business marketing like
Innovation early investor in Uber like
there's just so many things when I think
about this incredible company you know
when I go and speak at like the national
Dairy
Association it's a it's not as much on
the head of what this is and for me
there's just an enormous amount of
admiration I have for this org so thank
you so much for having me and more
importantly what I get excited about is
as someone who has been an entrepreneur
his whole life and who's been an
investor especially in a lot of
companies that look the profile of this
company you're always curious which
organizations have that stomach to go
through the different chapters right as
again Facebook and Twitter and Tumblr
and other companies that I invested in
early on
those are the ones that I can speak to
and it's like cool there's plenty of
companies that had incredible starts
that I was involved in that you don't
know like I don't think a lot of people
here know what the yo Bongo is
right and I think about that crossroads
and I think it's an interesting time in
general and I also think that
2024 is going to be a really fun
business year because I think we're
settled into a true postco world and and
I kind of like when it's real I think
when there's too much money in the
system like the VC decade of the past or
when it's like too you know obviously
when we print money and give it to
everybody people are just buying dumb
we just live through that I just
feel like we're in this really cool spot
where it's real and I think real
companies will emerge during real times
and so for me I was pretty excited to
say yes to this because I'm like oh this
is going to be a cool one to watch in
five or seven years cuz I have some
sneaky intuition of how this movie plays
out so I just want to thank all of you
for allowing me to be here look on the
flight down here I posted an Instagram
post and in the copy of like 8% of the
Year is already gone which like really
shook me because as you know the world
has gotten soft and nobody really worked
until the Tuesday after Martin Luther
King this year and so it took about two
weeks for this year to even get started
and so like the fact that 8% of the Year
is already done has me like kind of a
little Shook and speaks to like the
urgency and like the focus I'm trying to
think about and I'm sure for all of you
you're thinking that through it's it's
fun that you brought everyone together I
think there's a lot of value in that I'm
thinking a lot about the Serendipity and
things of that nature also what's
interesting for me is as someone who
grew up from 14 to 34 years old working
retail you know Monday through Saturday
uh from 8:00 a.m. to 10: p.m. in a
liquor store my whole life and then over
the last 15 years have built a marketing
Corporation of 2,000 people it's also
like really fun to in an audience that's
mixed with remarkable corporate people
but then also people in the trenches and
as somebody who's lived 20 years in both
categories if I just may for two seconds
and this is with Incredible love for
everyone that's in corporate can we take
one second and clap it the up for
the people that are actually in the
F like maybe a little louder cuz they're
actually you
know
oh and you know what it was funny it was
funny cuz I was thinking about it I was
like this company also represents
how I've lived my last 40 years and I
was like I was like all right I want to
say this cuz I really feel it I wonder
how it's going to land cuz I want to
make sure all the corporate people know
I'm not
razing but I was I I actually said to
myself I helicoptered over from New York
real quick this morning to do this in my
mind I was like it'll be interesting how
that reaction goes will be a really
interesting indication to me of where
the company is and so kudos to y'all I
appreciate the fact that everybody in
corporate understands the difference of
people that are actually in the trenches
every day that reaction doubled down my
confidence of where go Puffs going so
thank you for that so really that it's
real talk it's Real
Talk cuz when it snows you can't just be
like Oh I'm going going to zoom you have
to go in it's real
anyway I think that the thing that I'm
most thinking about of like what's
everyone in here thinking about like how
are they thinking about this year I
think perspective is a big focus of mine
I think that how one sees life is how it
is right I've been very like weirded out
by this whole half glass full half glass
empty thing and that that really struck
me too as I thought about this talk I'm
like just wonder how people are thinking
about at gopuff right because for
me again just to put it actually how
many people here know very little about
me or have no idea who the I am
just raise your hands real loud all
right that
hurts let me actually I I thought that
might be the case so let me give you
three seconds on this to set up what I
was about to say so real quick for
everyone who just raised her hands I was
born in the Soviet Union I immigrated to
the us we lived in queens in a studio
apartment with eight family members it
was ghetto you know immigrant
like by the time I was eight I
realized my parents aren't buying me
toys or video games so I was
straight lemonade stands like when I was
seven cuz we moved to Edison New Jersey
when I was seven I literally tricked or
manipulated or convinced or motivated my
six best friends to stand behind
lemonade stands all day long and this
group is way too young but for the
couple of you that are in your 40s or
above I don't know if you remember back
in the 80s we had something called Big
Wheels they were like like that you
remember that I used to ride my big
wheels at like 5:00 p.m. during the
summer at the end of the day I would
ride my big wheels to the six Lemonade
Stand locations that I created and
picked up my money like I was
Tony
Soprano and then I went into baseball
cards and was making like two I mean
$2,000 a weekend selling baseball cards
in 7th and eighth grade in 1985
like real talk when you have $10,000 in
cash under your bed and you're 11 and
you're not selling weed you're a
entrepreneur and then thank
you then my dad ruined my life I was
making all this money and then I turned
14 oldest son born in the Old Country my
dad went from a stock boy making two
bucks an hour in a liquor store to
owning a small store in Springfield New
Jersey and so Merchant son like I had to
go work there and I went from making
$1,000 $2,000 a weekend selling baseball
cards in the malls in New Jersey being
cool and living to making two
bucks an hour working 14 hours a day in
my dad's liquor store and I mean every
day I don't know many I don't know how
many of you have a Soviet father but it
was like no it was 14 hours a
day 7 hours in the basement bagging ice
for the cooler and then coming up and
stocking shelves and that like became
the foundation of my career then I
realized people collected wine and then
in 1996 I launched one of the first
e-commerce wine businesses in America
America called Wine Library blew up my
dad's business and that kind of is how
my career took off my dad really didn't
I again how many people here immigrants
like their parents were born in outside
the US or you have raise your hands so
you guys know like my dad didn't pay me
even though I worked from 22 to 34
in that liquor store I built that
business from a three to a $75 million
business and I never got paid more than
80 $90,000 a year even though I did all
that and so I had to go do my own thing
but the foundation of that real
brick-and mortar retail e-commerce grind
and then over the last 14 years I became
an early investor on Facebook Twitter
Uber that changed obviously a lot for me
but I built a company called Vayner
media which is one of the largest
marketing companies in the world 2,000
employees
globally what what what that does back
to why I said I feel so connected to
youall is I've just really lived both
sides of the equation especially can I
hear some noise for the folks in
[Applause]
here
yeah some
good so I have a crazy good relationship
with y'all though complicated meaning I
really love you cuz I grew up like you
but I also grew up in an era where BMA
was such this iconic thing in California
and when I was like 15 I used to like
literally play like Genesis I'm like yo
one day I'm going to put out of
business so it's nice to be with
all you um you know of course then for
all that noise like for you can't
imagine like how much I think about what
is the marketing going to be like how do
we get people in store what are the
trends you know it's crazy to watch how
people have different Trends in drinking
alcohol for example if you know anything
about wine how many people here have had
rosé wine Make some
noise I worked in my dad's liquor store
from
1990 pretty much every when I was a kid
in school every weekend and summer
vacation and then the day I graduated
literally I drove from Boston and in the
middle of the day I got there at 3:30 on
that day and literally worked until 7
like it was no time down so basically
from 1990 to
2015 I worked in a liquor store my whole
life when I tell you we would sell from
1990 to 2005 we would sell four cases of
Rosé a year a year now we sell 100 cases
of Rosé a week in the winter not even in
the summer as you all know that consumer
shift is the most interesting I grew up
hearing War stories that people used to
drink whiskey in Bourbon because in my
era nobody did it was all vodka and then
became tequila right and people like the
old liquor salesman would be like no no
no like 25 old women used to drink Brown
Goods I'm like you're crazy is
that serious and then obviously over the
last 10 years that has come back
consumer Trends are incredibly
interesting it's one of the most
fascinating things and I think it plays
out in the things you sell both on the
liquor side and on the snack side I
think it's going to be really
interesting because what's amazing about
your organization from my perspective is
you're close to the customer you have
the data you get to see it that's going
to end up playing out to be a very big
deal and whoever's closest to the
customer wins there is nothing else like
to me all of My Success in my career has
been customer my employees and then me
and I give my dad a lot of credit for
always caring about the store more than
his children I've gotone to therapy for
it
but I respect the out of it because
I understand it and I think again that's
going to be an interesting ride to watch
look I think the biggest things that I'm
thinking through
is one one thing that I asked Dan
actually in the Green Room like talk to
me about the you know like the stock
options things that it's like owners and
I'm like that's super interesting
because I think that gets it really
motivating really fast right like back
to like people in the trenches real
quick not like want to just want to make
make sure that people understand like
the upside of that game think when
things are on paper like I it's been uh
I'll tell you the story that most hit me
when I understood the stock option play
I was like Facebook was obviously my
biggest win in my career right and last
night ironically going through social I
got home late around midnight and I saw
that the stock market had a big day I I
tend to look at my portfolio like one
like I don't know once every three
months but I just happened to see like
oh Dow Jones went off I'm let me look
and I saw that Facebook was at $400 a
share and immediately I got like the
worst Pit in my stomach not for me from
the day I invested in Facebook four
years before it's IP po to this morning
I've never sold a
share because I believed in the founder
right obviously I'm very aware of what
people think about Zuck and the way the
media has played it out but as the guy
driving it I always told my whole family
that the day he's out is the day I share
sell but until he's out I hold forever
the reason I'm bringing it up is what
I'm most fascinated about
2024 what I'm most fascinated about
every employee in here at this moment in
in the history of goat Puff's company as
a complete outside Observer who watches
the game is I'm fascinated by people's
lack of
patience the reason I bring up this
Facebook story to you this morning is
because I was early at Facebook because
I made a video in
20076 that said Facebook should be
worried about this new app called
Twitter and it went viral inside of
Facebook and I got called to go give a
speech check this out the entire company
of Facebook at the time when I gave my
talk of why Twitter was going to be a
thing was half the size of this audience
right now it was early I didn't even
know zux was in the audience back to how
like weird and different he is he was in
the way back and I did my Spiel and in
2006 I said social media is going to win
because it's human
behavior that's it like the reason
everybody wears the hat and the clothes
they wear is to communicate to others
the reason we buy fancy cars is to
communicate to others almost everything
we do as humans is to communicate to
others obviously with our mouths and the
way we roll but with subtle that
you don't even realize every photo you
ever posted on social is subconsciously
something you're trying to say position
yourself front at worst or communicate
Your Truth at best and so that's how it
is and so I understood that anyway that
struck a chord we hit it off we had
dinner and I invested in Facebook very
quickly after that and I mean all of my
savings I bet the
farm the part about patience that I want
to talk about in 2024 is about what
happened next three years later it went
public over those three years before it
went public I got to know a bunch of the
top 100
exacts when the stock came out some of
you might remember this because you were
youngsters or you know it was a big
moment it opened at about $40 a share
42 it went down to 19 pretty
quickly most of the friends that I made
in those three years that were top 300
400 first 500 employees of Facebook sold
somewhere between 25 and
19 they made a lot of M the ones I knew
were there super early and very SAR they
made a lot like nope this story is not
to cry for those
what's interesting is
seeing them over the last 10 years
what's interesting for me is someone who
got in for much less much later the fact
that I'm going to end up making more
money on Facebook than a lot of those
people with
me and it was just one big game of lack
of
patience and so I think what I'm most
focused about in 2024 personally is
thinking about that how much of my
decision making is based on tomorrow and
how much is it for a year from now you
know what I love about retail what I
love about retail is the signature story
that is still told in my dad's liquor
story even though I haven't been there
dayto day for a decade is a story of
December 18th in our store when I was
the most important salesman on the
floor and it was snowing and we had just
done the internet thing for the last
four or five years and we got a phone
call from a woman in Bergen County New
Jersey who was not yelling at us she was
like when I got on the phone she sounded
like Yoda she was like a
thousand but she was complaining that it
was important for her to get and this is
a good one especially for the BevMo
crowd her Behringer white
zendel Ros used to be sweet for all of
you that don't know in America her
Binger White zendel had not been
delivered and it was a whole Todo and
her son called and says you don't
understand the FedEx that got delivered
anyway punchline is this
it in one of our busiest days of the
year off of me learning the this while I
was on the floor from the internet
Department I ran downstairs to the
warehouse grabbed a 15 pack of baringer
white zadel threw it into my car and
drove to Bergen County and delivered it
personing and drove back and was off the
floor for about 2 or 3 hours during that
time many Top Dog customers came in only
willing to work with me ready to spend
five 10 $15,000 on their collection and
left when I got back the core crew was
like what the
what I knew then and I did many
things like this this is the one I just
get to tell on stage what I knew then
was actions have to set the tone for a
culture what I knew was I was going to
take a l in the short term on that day
but I felt that it would be something
that everybody in the crew especially
because I knew I was looking to build
long term and the 20 people people that
were around me I was hoping and played
out would be there for 10 15 years I
needed something to point to for them to
understand what our DNA
was both on the corporate side and in
the trenches here I think we think too
short
term the reason I tell that story is
with the hope that one person decides
like that makes sense when I face
something
tomorrow do I think about it from the
shortterm reality of it or do I think
about it as is this an opportunity to
set the tone for what we're trying to
do I think that kind of mentality of
patience and brand building and culture
building is everything you know to
me uh for example this event with this
event when when I was asked to do it
back in the winter I was so pumped that
you were all going to be together I'm
ever just thinking like yes that's
exactly right and I'm a businessman and
I paying attention so I'm aware of
what's macro going on with gopuff and
they're trying to be strategic about
what they spend their money on and not
and I'm like good for them to understand
this like for
example what he just did was
phenomenal I hope I Dro three or four
things that make you think about
something and maybe do something this
will be a good day of like content I'm
sure but everything that happens on this
stage today
is
compared to if you take
advantage of all the downtime all those
minutes in between lunch break I don't
know what the you you doing lunch
you're lunch I don't eat lunch I think
it's a complete waste of
time retail that's what the
teaches
here so when you're at lunch
today if you can do me one favor what
will normally happen in this environment
is you're going to sit with your homies
the people you're probably sitting with
right now the only thing that matters
about like this is that the people
in here who have the ability because
they have enough extrovert enough
confidence enough self-esteem please
challenge yourself to go and say what's
up to somebody you don't recognize go
sit with somebody you don't know that
interconnected tissue is everything that
is the only way corporations teams
companies win so I highly ask the people
in here who have it in them to go and do
that to set the tone during the down
periods of this event because that is
disproportionately why you should be
here can I get a little noise for the
people that feel they can do
[Applause]
that look I think I think that there's
so much opportunity in front but I want
to talk about something else that's a
little bit on what I've been talking
about and I'm going to frame it up for
all of you as another thing to
contemplate and again I'll be honest
with you when I do these kind of talks
I'm little I'm more about the humans
than I am about the logo like I like the
GOP puff guys I like Dan a lot uh you
know I'm I'm a fan from afar of the
business but what I'm about to talk
about I think is essential for all of
you for your career within or after when
you're not here or whatever plays out
for all of you what I've been talking
about for the last 5 to seven minutes
and what I'd like to frame up for all of
you as one man's point of view of
something that has clearly worked for
everybody at all levels in the business
world over the last 30 years that I've
observed is scaling the
unscalable so I want to spend a few
minutes on this concept and just put
this in your mind scaling the unscalable
me driving that Binger white synel for 2
hours for something that was like $30
for a case was scaling the
unscalable the thing that I really want
to talk to some of the field leaders
especially in the stores or even
corporate is I can't get over this mind
that if you're really as customer
Centric as you like to say you are to
the world and I see how you try to
position yourself I'd like to challenge
everyone here to do more scaling of the
unscaled aailable for
customers so for example I'm about to
tell you a story that is also iconic to
me that I think gopuff can scale 10,000
times better than I did 15 years ago and
I think this is for corporate and then
I've got one for the field so for
corporate so Twitter came out I was
fascinated by it I was like the world's
changing the internet's changing and I
was really focused on lifetime value and
retention I'm sure for the people in
analytics in this company when you look
at all the people that have bought from
gopuff or
BevMo but haven't bought from you in 6
months or 12 months you just look at it
like it's all right there the re
the lapsed user is one of the most
interesting things in business so I was
obsessed with that I was like we have
the best you know we were really rolling
at Wine Library like we have the best
prices we have the best selection I felt
real confident I was like why isn't
everybody buying everything from us like
I wanted it and so I started thinking
about okay we're doing all this internet
right but we're not doing like the
heavy touch you know the that
locks it in so I said to the
team I have this idea boarding a plane
to Napa ironically I had the idea I
called my best friend Brandon who runs
the store I said I want don't you to do
something I want every order that comes
on wi library.com I want you to Google
the person's name and see if you can
find them obviously some people have
John Smith that'll be hard luckily some
people have Gary vaynerchuck and there's
only one of them and you can find them
if you find someone who's you really
know who the it is it's that person
let me
know they found someone I said now I
want you to go and find them on Twitter
can you find and this was Twitter early
so like most people weren't on so I knew
it would take a little
bit about a week or two later I get a
call we got some dude I'm like
amazing
so he they go we got this dude he he bad
news this is going to really make the
people laugh bad news though we
found him but he bought a case of Santa
Margarita Peno
graio the shittiest most overpriced wine
of all time Real Talk super overrated
kudos to them it's one of the few wine
brands that have built an actual brand
so people are buying what is really $4
Pino Brie for 25
bucks thank
you I go that's cool I go here's what I
want you so I go tell so I'm on the
phone with Brandon he goes I found his
Twitter I go what's he
tweeting this is where the story gets
interested every tweet out of this
dude's mouth is Jay Cutler I love
you so this dude lives in Chicago and
he's a huge Bears fan and he's tweeting
like now we all tweet along with sports
all the time but this was early and
it's like Jak Cutler why' you throw that
pass Jay Cutler don't do that great job
J it's Jay Cutler
for the majority of you don't know I'll
just say one more time Jay Culler was
the quarterback of the Chicago Bears of
the
time I'm like okay I go Brandon here's
what I want you to do I want you to go
to eBay and I want you to buy a Jay
Cutler jersey signed in a frame and send
it to him with a note that says thank
you for shopping at Wine Library right
it's like bro that's like 350 bucks we
made like $89 in the whole case of Santa
Margarita I go I know I know I go trust
me I just want to do this so I'm
thinking we're going to send this
Jay Cutler fanatic a jersey he's
going to be blown away and then
I'll show Brandon and the team just like
my baringer story I'm like look he spent
all his money with us over the next two
years let's do this I had a whole master
plan I'm so pumped I'm like I'm a
I'm a genius I'm like
yes and then real life hits this we send
this dude this thing we don't hear a
peep nothing fa now it's a month
it's two now I'm I like you know when
you're like picking a scab like now I'm
like just addicted to this I got
a million things going on all I give a
about is some random dentist in
Chicago who I sent to Jay Cutler
Jersey to that bought penino
Grio from the most overpriced
producer in the world and hasn't said
Thank
you so I'm dead like for those months
I'm like really annoyed about it we do
some other little things but this one
really stuck to me cuz it was so
egregious right like it was so big for
what he
bought and then one of the most
interesting things happen I get a phone
call from Brandon again Brandon is
currently right now in Wine Library in
Springfield New Jersey not too far from
here like I met him on the first day of
high school so my best friend but also
runs my family business he calls me he's
like you're never going to believe this
and just by the way he said it you know
when you know somebody for 15 years and
you're like I knew it was that I was
like the Jay Cutler guy replied
he goes no
look at this
he goes just stick with me
he goes let me read this I'm like go
ahead so reads some name Plano Texas and
he rattles off like a
$7,000 red burgundy order right so just
really high-end single Vineyard stuff
like just really esoteric small producer
Red burgundies Seven G's I'm like okay
that's a good order but I'm like but
what what's the punch cuz I knew he
wouldn't just call me for now I'm like
yo what he goes he goes no no he's like
wait for it he goes he goes now let me
read you what's in the note so that's
when I knew it would get good I'm like
what he goes hey um first of all you
have an amazing burgundy selection can I
speak to somebody I'm looking for some
other stuff second I live in Texas it's
hot as can you please hold it for a
while he goes
P.S my best friend lives in
Chicago and you sent him a J Cutler
Jersey and that's how I found out about
your
store
PSS I'm a huge Bruce Springsteen
[Applause]
fan that happened 15 years ago I
think about it all the time and I think
when I was you know thinking about this
talk I was like what's the move that
they can actually do like coming and
giving a talk you only got a limited
amount of time and like you could talk
about mindset and perspective and I'm
touching on different as you can
tell but I was like what's the action
that this company can actually do that
can
reinforce so they can taste it of what
I'm actually talking about when I
analyze from afar the virtual and
physical combo of gopuff and BevMo and
especially really knowing the
business and understanding what's
happening in the California Market not
obviously you're in other markets as
well Liquor Bar these things I really do
believe both for yourselves and for your
customers that 2024 is an incredible
opportunity to scale the
unscalable there's a lot of ways to
spend marketing dollars you can run
Facebook ads and Google ads and inapp
there's other ways to spend money things
that create debt like buying a J Cutler
Jersey and sending it to someone you
were sitting on on both companies
unlimited data unlimited all of the
magic sits there we have just gotten
into a world where everything is digital
and virtual and scalable and AI is
coming and it's all this and all that's
happening is we're getting further away
from a business era that our
grandparents lived
in I actually believe the way our
grandparents did
business is actually the real
opportunity of the next decade it is the
people that understand whoever brings
the most
Humanity wins I believe that that will
matter for the way you frame up how much
you care about
customers I actually believe there's a
more important story in here which is
what if you did that to each
other back to what I asked for for you
to consider at lunch what if you
actually went
deeper with each other what if you
actually
cared like for real what ends up
happening is it's like
sports how many people here with
sports Make Some
Noise actually this is perfect I'm so
pumped right now it just hit me my
number one example for what I'm about to
say happened in Philadelphia I don't
remember the year I think it was 2002 3
4 but there was a year that the Eagles
anybody an Eagles fan
here good so you're going to remember
good I see you quick remember that super
team you guys built like 15 years ago
was supposed to be the greatest
team of all time you got the cornerback
from the Raiders it was going to like
dominate I was like this is boring
they're going to go 16-0 and win the
Super Bowl I don't like the NFL being
like this it's like baseball this is
I was and then you guys went
like eight and8 missed the playoffs and
sucked
that story is how I look I've made
a lot of money investing and I've lost a
lot of money investing and I've built
two very successful companies with my
hands and then I also started resi the
restaurant app inside of anner media and
I had a direct consumer wine brand
called empathy that I sold to
consolation so I've had wins and I've
had plenty of losses the only common
thread of the Investments the boards I
sit on the only common threat there's a
million variables of what makes somebody
win sometimes the CEO she or he is just
too talented and they will it to
success other times there's some random
outside factors people get caught at
time there's things
but the only Common Thread that I see in
the world of making something win is how
much the locker room likes each
other that Eagles team was uncomfortably
talented every dude in that locker room
was out for themselves and can give a
about their teammate that's why
they lost so
much when I think about the crossroads
of the business world we live in today
in the consumer lens when I think about
what your compe landscape would look
like both on BM Mo and gopuff in the
next decade the only thing that is clear
to me besides the fact from afar I'm
getting to know them I think your
Founders are really strong besides that
what is very obvious to me is the
outcome of your financial winnings here
your enjoyment here and what it sets you
up for because the best part is with all
respect to the founders everybody El the
best part of winning at gopuff during
this era is what it's sets you up for in
seven years if you win at a company like
this during this era that's real talk
that's for your
grandchildren and so there is so much
uncomfortable upside in this room but I
genuinely believe regardless of how
talented the top seven 10 15 people are
in this company the most obvious
variable of how well that all plays out
is how well the thousand people in this
room get along I really believe that not
on some Grandma sap be fooo woo woo
on some I only care about
winning I love business I've done it my
whole life and all I do is Observe and
it is the only common threat I've seen
and so I ask you as I bounce off this
stage to consider that framework because
I think the upside is there for
you and if you can find a way to be the
bigger person if you you can find a way
to scale the
unscalable first for each other and then
for your
customers I think you win I'd like to
see you win because I'm a Jets fan and I
don't get to win a
lot and so I like to see others win um
that's actually not true I want to
conest something because I just need to
get this off my chest this feels like a
good
medium there was obviously some big
football games this
Sunday
W for the people that do know actually
how many people here do know about me
and consume some of my content can you
clap it
up thank you so for those people in this
audience you're aware I'm a pretty
optimistic positive dude but
there's one version of me that isn't
football
Gary and football Gary is why I
understand why people are on tilt around
politics and around other cuz it's
the only place where I don't have my
emotions in check and I'm not proud of
who I am and I just want to get this out
cuz it's important to get out I
just want to confest something this
Sunday when the Lions were dominating
the
49ers I thought going into the game that
I was rooting for the Lions especially
because my brother and I have a sports
agency and we rep five Detroit Lions
including Aiden
Hutchinson so naturally I thought but
sports Gary kicked in at halftime and I
realized one of the things I most
believe in in the world that I ask all
of you to pay attention there is a lot
of sayings in life the most real one is
misery loves
company a lot of people in this room are
up right now because they're
spending too much time watching the news
or their social media feeds watching
people that are trying to Dag drag you
down into their unhappiness by selling
you
fear misery loves company in real life I
limit misery I limit my relatives and
friends who are not happy who are trying
to Dag me down I'm there for them but I
limit it in football Gary I don't I'm
super mad and I hate
everybody who's a Patriots
fan yeah I hate you so much
bro
like anyway I don't understand why we
don't love each other we're all just one
team but I do understand cuz I hate that
dude I liked him it's funny how life
works I liked him 15 minutes ago cuz I
saw that he had a wuang hoodie on I'm
like yo I with that dude but then
he said he was a Patriots fan anyway I
just want to get this off my chest I
have to conest it is scary to me how
much I wanted the Lions to lose cuz I
didn't want another shitty franchise to
go to the Super
Bowl
yeah anyway to end my speech 2024 don't
be football
Gary thank you so
much thank you my de thank you so much
goop have a great year B Mo I love
you